Salut, aujourd'hui c'est samedi et le samedi c'est le jour du master class.
Apparemment je parle un peu souvent trop près de la caméra.
Alors je me suis assis pour être sûr de pas trop coller mon visage.
Aujourd'hui c'est un master class mémoire, on en a fait quelques uns, on en a fait un sur la table de rappel, on en a fait un sur le palais mental
On en a fait une également sur le système PAO pour apprendre à retenir un jeu de carte en entier. Et dans les commentaires de toutes ces vidéos, j'ai checké aujourd'hui...
Vous m'avez souvent demandé comment faire pour retenir un texte.
Simplement un texte, ou une leçon, ou un cours...
Est-ce que qu'il y a vraiment une méthode pour faire ça ?
Oui !
J'ai pas pu m'empêcher de m'approcher !
C'est une méthode qui rejoint un petit peu la vidéo n° 86 sur comment booster sa mémoire deux fois plus rapidement.
Vous pouvez réellement retenir n'importe quel texte ou n'importe quel cours assez facilement
si vous y trouver une logique.
La méthode classique, évidemment  c'est de vouloir apprendre par coeur, par coeur et de se faire le discours intérieur en se le répétant en boucle.
C'est ce qu'on appelle le bourrage de crâne.
La méthode que je vous propose là est beaucoup plus longue en terme de préparation au travail.
Elle demande plus d'efforts au départ quand on n'a pas l'habitude,
quand je parle d'effort, c'est plus de créativité,
mais, elle permet de retenir plus facilement les choses dans le temps
puisque vous allez donner de la logique à l'information.
Pas de la logique forcément de compréhension, de la logique pour vous.
Vous allez établir un raisonnement au quasiment mot à mot
Je pourrais réellement vous en parler durant des heures pour ce master class,
mais ce qu'il faut retenir c'est l'essence même de la méthodologie.
L'essence même du travail qu'il y a à fournir.
Tous les coups sont permis pour trouver une mnémotechnie et une logique
et créer un chemin entre ses neurones pour retrouver toute l'information après à tout moment.
Je prends une page au hasard dans le livre "Alex au pays des chiffres".
J'ouvre à la page 129.
"Bouddha n'était pas le seul indien d'alors à s'intéresser à l'incroyablement grand et à l'infiniment petit, loin de là."
"La littérature sanscrite regorge de nombres astronomiques."
"Les adeptes du Jaïnisme, religion voisine de l'Hindouisme définissaient déjà le rajju
comme étant la distance parcourue en six mois par Dieu couvrant 100000 ..."
Là, on prend quand même le bon exemple.
Je comprends rien à ce que je lis.
C'est pas grave. Mon but, c'est de vous faire voir comment je ferais si je devais apprendre ça par coeur.
La technique consiste à prendre le temps de détailler phrase par phrase, mot à mot
et à chaque fois de me trouver comme un petit raisonnement, comme une petite logique,
un petit point d'accroche, un ancrage mental.
Bouddha, ce sera mon point de départ, c'est Bouddha, j'ai la vision de Bouddha.
On va dire que c'est une leçon, ou c'est un texte, ou c'est un discours ou c'est un cours, peu importe.
Je sais que ça parle de Bouddha donc c'est Bouddha.
Bouddha n'était pas le seul indien d'alors.
C'est clairement facile de retenir que Bouddha était le seul indien.
Par contre, la négation, là pour moi elle est compliquée à retenir.
Si je devais absolument apprendre par coeur, mot à mot,
je vais me dire Bouddha, bouda c'est comme le verbe bouder, il boude, il est pas content.
Donc Bouddha il est pas content, c'est pas qu'il était le seul indien,
c'est justement qu'il n'était pas le seul indien.
J'en profite pour vous dire que d'une manière générale, le cerveau a du mal à retenir la négation.
Donc il faut trouver absolument des petites méthodes comme ça.
Je visualise en fait Bouddha tout seul au milieu d'un champs de tipis
d'indiens d'Amérique pour le coup parce que l'image elle est plus marquante.
Et donc Bouddha il boudait et il boudait au milieu de ce truc parce qu'il était pas le seul indien.
Y a d'autres indiens qui arrivent dans mon image.
"d'alors à s'intéresser à l'incroyablement grand et à l'infiniment petit"
Alors, "d'alors", "d'alors", je vais mettre de l'or dans les mains de mon image de Bouddha, au tout départ.
Donc je vois Bouddha tout seul au milieu des tipis,
il y a des indiens qui arrivent au loin et il a de l'or dans les mains.
Et comme il boude Bouddha ça fait Bouddha n 'était pas le seul indien d'alors.
Et d'alors, ça finit par un S. Le S je vais le visualiser à plat.Le S qui est à la fin d'alors.
Comme si il y a un côté qui pointait le ciel et un autre qui pointait la terre.
Et celui vers le ciel, c'est ce qui est immense, c'est  l'incroyablement grand.
Incroyablement grand, ça me fait penser à incroyable Hulk.
C'est des choses grosses, incroyables : incroyablement grand, incroyablement Hulk, vers le haut.
Et vers le bas c'est tout petit, c'est infime donc c'est l'infiniment petit.
Je pense que c'est ça, hein ? Oui.
Ce qui me donne donc Bouddha en train de bouder au milieu de tous les tipis, avec les indiens qui arrivent.
Il a de l'or dans les mains. Alors ça finit par un S.
Le S il est à l'horizontal, il tombe, il est à côté de Bouddha.
Il y a un côté qui pointe vers le haut, vers le ciel, vers le grand, l'immense, comme l'incroyable Hulk,
donc l'incroyablement grand.
Et vers le bas c'est tout petit, c'est infime, c'est l'infiniment petit.
Et que ce soit l'incroyablement grand ou l'infiniment petit,
ces deux choses sont très loin d'ici, très loin de là.
Vous avez vu le temps que j'ai passé sur une seule phrase c'est à dire sur les deux premières lignes.
J'ai passé aussi un peu de temps à vous l'expliquer mais je passe autant de temps à le faire, quasiment.
Sauf que comme j'ai l'habitude, je trouve mes logiques un peu plus rapidement.
Quand vous allez commencer à faire ça, vous allez peut-être avoir l'impression de perdre du temps au départ, à l'apprentissage.
Alors que vous gagnez du temps. Vous gagnez du temps sur l'apprentissage, vous gagnez du temps sur la durée.
Parce que vous avez moins besoin de réviser, moins besoin de tout repasser dans votre tête.
C'est juste qu'on a pas l'habitude de consacrer autant de temps à la compréhension initiale, à la gestion des images.
Si vous le faites, vous allez voir ensuite que le bénéfice il est ouf puisque tout va vous revenir instantanément.
Quand je redis la phrase qu'on vient d'apprendre ensemble, je ne cherche pas quelle logique j'ai mis.
Elle me revient instantanément. Bouddha, j'ai tout qui me vient d'un coup.
Bouddha qui boude. D'ailleurs vous avez vu, j'ai froncé, j'ai boudé.
Donc Bouddha n'était pas le seul indien d'alors
à s'intéresser à l'incroyablement grand et à l'infiniment petit, loin de là.
J'ai saccadé en disant la phrase parce que j'ai laissé toute ma logique me revenir,
les petites images, tous mes check points de mémoire.
Je pense que vous avez compris la méthode.
La suite c'est "La littérature sanscrite regorge de nombres astronomiques."
Instantanément, je vois le mot sanscrite et regorge.
Sanscrite, dans sanscrite il y a sang, et dans regorge il y a gorge.
Je sais déjà que je vais me faire une logique entre le mot sang et le mot gorge.
La littérature : pour me souvenir de la littérature,
il faut déjà que je me souvienne que la prochaine phrase commence par "la".
Ben c'est pas dur, la dernière phrase "loin de là" finit par "la".
Donc dans ma tête je me dis juste la fin comme le début comme des dominos en fait,
"là" va avec "la".Donc là-la. Là-la.
Littérature. J'ai un livre qui me vient directement à l'esprit.
Tiens, je vais garder l'image du domino d'ailleurs. Là-la
Sur la fin d'un domino y a "là", sur le début de l'autre domino y a un "la" aussi.
Et la fin de ce domino là, c'est un gros livre.
Mais c'est un gros livre ensanglanté en fait.
A cause d'organes qui sont en train de gicler sur lui.
Et donc là ça me fait "loin de là - la littérature sanscrite regorge "
Etc, etc ... Je vais pas vous le faire en entier parce qu'il y aurait aucun intérêt pour vous.
Ce qui m'importait vraiment dans ce master class,
c'est que vous compreniez la méthode de travail à placer en amont
lors d'un apprentissage complet par coeur.
Plus vous consacrez de temps comme ça à bien comprendre le texte,
à bien comprendre les mécanismes cachés en fait, invisibles,
qui vont résonner avec votre logique à vous,
un peu comme en trouvant le S avec l'incroyablement grand et l'infiniment petit,
plus vous allez trouver votre logique, vous allez prendre le temps de la regarder, de la détailler,
plus vous allez créer en fait comme un réseau de neurones qui va fonctionner réellement
puisque vous avez plein de points comme ça qui se rattachent.
Ça marche bien aussi pour retenir un texte au théâtre mais ça marche aussi pour retenir n'importe quel cours
un poème, une phrase, une thèse que vous devez défendre.
Ça peut aussi être associé aussi au palais mental et à la table de rappel dans les anciennes vidéos qu'on a vu.
Rendez tout ça vivant, imagé et logique pour votre cerveau et ça marchera très bien.
Si vous avez peur que moi par contre, j'oublie de faire encore des vidéos sur ce genre de thème,
vous pouvez me donner un bon moyen mnémotechnique en laissant un pouce en l'air.
Merci à vous d'être ici,  merci à tous ceux qui sous-titrent les vidéos.
Ça c'est très utile pour les malentendants, bravo à vous et merci beaucoup.
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la chaîne. N'oubliez pas c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an,
avec des formats très précis chaque jour de la semaine.
Vous pouvez commenter, je lis tous vos messages et en plus j'y réponds avec grand plaisir.
Et rendez-vous demain à 11h pour le prochain mental vlog. Ciao !